ma da [ __ ]
stella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo vi dò io sono faringei e
oggi siamo su cry of iran
raga cry of here è una era praticamente
una mod di half life solo da pochissimo
è diventato un gioco assai su steam
ho preso è dio mio non vedo l'ora di
iniziarlo perché so già che sarà
fantastico sotto ogni punto di vista
dato che non avete consigliato in
tantissimi visto che i giochi che gli
consigliate sono sempre epici
non oso pensare che cosa fantastica
possa essere se mi prendo qualche
infarto è colpa vostra
però va bene iniziava a sto punto
andiamo sul mio game
e allora difficoltà 9 a fare le parti
deficienti andiamo su medium facciamo
vedere che non siamo proprio deficienti
al massimo anche se comunque io ho già
morirei in facile sono sicuro non è il
treno ecco perché facciano vedere tre
comunque
sono bellissimi uno sguardo da chi ha
voglia di vivere anche piovendo tanto
fair come un cassetto straface piange
perché piangeva cosetta lasciato la
ragazza che è successo pià piange ha
pianto così osta starnutendo non lo so
non ho capito bene il senso di tutto
questo c'è qualcuno che cammina raga ma
sto gioco si può giocare
o dobbiamo vedere cioè non ho capito ma
se sempre lui ok
tra l'altro le metropoli piene di gente
c'è gente che dopo dvd rifà artista c'è
qualcuno che striscia a caldo c'è
qualcuno che trichet chiedendo aiuto si
è accesa una macchina raga sta
succedendo un colpo di scena penso che
questo non già con intenzioni buona
capito il gioco
spero vi sia piaciuta già stati
investiti o mio dio cioè non siamo
neanche partiti siamo morti
oddio che brutta faccia c'è proprio non
poteva essere una bella gnocca no a
questo è il ricordo di quando la
macchina mia squillaci kato al muro
perfetto ma anche cosa cazzo
cos'è alzati a tutto o prendi cosa che
cazzo sociale rai sa cosa sta succedendo
sono ci sono ma sono povera all'ospedale
mappa di che cazzo
raga era mi sono svegliato veramente
sono in un ospedale e mi sono svegliato
con una macchina fotografica che
affidano c'è la coca cioè la ragazza
coca la voglia c'è una macchina c'è una
macchina fotografica benissimo ci siamo
partiti con una macchina si può fare qui
fotografare sono un paparazzo raga sono
un paparazzo ebbene sono io io ho
paparazzo la gente benissimo devo andare
di qua perché c'è la locandina di the
grudge
praga questa questa locandina di the
grudge il film ma che cazzo però vabbè
andiamo avanti ci siamo svegliati allora
in un ospedale buio a caso con una
macchina fotografica
ok per haga è un nuovo tipo di apertura
porte c'è bisogna fare le foto per
aprire le porte e cos'è sì sì
fotografare si fotografano le forze ti
odio [ __ ] ti odio anch'io
l'attività di tutto questo quale non lo
so cos'è una boxe raga c'era un morto
non posso più fare il flash c'è lo puoi
fare soltanto una volta cioè quando
quando c'è la xe puoi fare una botola
io non mi ci ficco dentro non aiuti a
che mi guardate così io non mi ci ficco
dentro la botola però ci vado bene sono
caduto dopo ok perfetto da cani non so
dove sto andando infilarmi ci sono porte
ovunque andiamo avanti la casta
diventando inquietante cioè più buio di
non so cosa non ho mai giocato un gioco
così al buio ok quando chi cazzo è
questo 6
raga non funziona più
scavalca le forze si possa lanciare si è
fatta ragazze la qualcuno di la prima
vabbè andiamo di questo punto la caccia
un'altra hicks che cazzo non ero io c
ero io va pensato fosse uno specchio
invece no era qualcuno dietro allo
specchio e qualcuno raga basta giocare
sto gioco non mi piace raga non va bene
così
babbo andiamo avanti c'è quel che ci
sono sempre visto ovunque sta diventando
che tantissima cosa c'è una ics in fondo
cazzo come ci arrivo una [ __ ]
ma che cazzo erano [ __ ] cosa cazzo
mio dio raga io sto tremando cosa cazzo
è a quella roba ma che ma stiamo
scherzando no no no no voi siete dei
maledetti a consigliarmi sull over sta
roba qui ma perché mi consigliate sti
giochi o mio dio
sì ho un coltello capitolo 1 perso nella
città no capitolo 1 cazzo io non gioca
sta roba
maledetti che mi consigliate questi
giochi
raga non ha senso vabbè andiamo avanti
di qualche redo che debbo cosa cos'è
puoi cambiare l'impugnatura madonna che
figo puoi cambiare l'impugnatura né il
coltello premi tab per accedere
alimentari ok praga e la mode e
bellissima c'è fatta da dio però non
possono mettere in parti c'è se succede
di nuovo io muoio mi ricordo un casino
gray buongiorno chi sta a chi era quello
non lo so questa porta si apre non c'era
qualcuno che cela qualcuna cos'è è un è
un lucchetto perfetto trova il codice
per poter e non lo so dice vabbè
torniamo dopo ma vera che non si apre
non capiscono anche qua il codice perché
ovviamente non ce l'abbiamo ancora
allora ok vado accoltellare luci giro
devo andare a perfetto c'è una roba di
qua
ok piano però è il cazzo di tuoni
e va bene o di qua c'è una c'è un'altra
strada questo posso scassare non c'è un
camion
prendi il caso era già motion e non c'è
verso non ce la faremo mai uscire di qua
lo so già ce ne è un sottopassaggio e
c'è nebbia c'è nebbia non è né cos'è il
tuo cellulare può essere utilizzato come
fonte di luce per navigare nell'oscurità
premi il tasto 1 per attivare la luce è
aspettare un attimo
ok mamma vi mando un messaggio dove sei
viene a casa più presto possibile che
sta diventando boias imam arrivo prepara
la crostata che sono lì in cinque minuti
non c'è la luce che casi ci c'è la luce
cazzo dico però non è buio quindi non ha
senso c'è una bici che cosa cazzo dio
che porta prendiamola pc dai cazzo va
bene un posto neanche presi io prenderei
volentieri la pc che me ne vado più in
fretta di qua per ora è un problema se
ciò il cellulare perché posso prendere
soltanto a pugni non è che tutto stronzo
sto bussando a free le cose
il problema è che se tengo cellulare non
posso tenere la il coltello quindi un po
una cosa svantaggiata prendo punito
torce e anche all'aperto cioè non ho mai
e all'aperto in una maniera incredibile
sono nelle piazze nonostante sia
l'avvento c'è perché c'è una zucca cosa
cazzo ci fa una zucca cui brutta stronzo
a voi per farmi prendere i corpi a
brutta bastarda che mi segui vabbè non
importa acqua dentro cerci pc può
entrare credo forse sì si può entrare
bene
dicevo nonostante sia all'aperto c'è ma
fa paura uguale non c'è nulla faccio un
computer farmi locale su facebook c'è
username sky longo vero cielo lungo
è pieno raga e pieno di macchine sul
fatto che non c'è la targa anche
italiana mi sembrano va beh sembra
quella italiana comunque c'è un
foglietto l'ho visto debito il 5 54
penso sia una penso sia questa la
password a the beatles
a è una s questa va bene 54 però il
problema che non sol username cos'è john
lennon
c'è ancora una volta qui ok c'è un altro
foglietto cos'è el user name confuse di
user fantastico mammamia epico questo
punto dovremmo esserci allora inter user
name ci siamo non è sky longa
con fused ed user perfetto invece la
password ed ere beatles 54 che 54 ok il
1599 david perfetto ci siamo chiude deve
entrare su facebook start setup the
network josé gil cento cos'è sta roba
1500 mah forse la combinazione del
lucchetto credo 1599 ok dobbiamo uscire
usciamo alle 2 51 del pomeriggio non
sembra vabbè usciamo di cui si esce
come si esce eccola raga devo andare e
cosa cazzo era raga c'è qualcuno di
fuori aiuto come vieni brutto stronzo è
aperta la porta è aperta
raga aperta la porta maledizione chi è
c'era qualcuno non me lo sono sognato
maledizione devo tornare indietro
lucchetto 1599 cuore c'era qualcuno
ragazzi l'ho visto maledizione l'ho
visto non sono pazzo brutto stronzo se
provi a farti vedere una donna
dov'è il vero paradiso ecco ci siamo le
procure perfetto ci sono che ci siamo
direi che possiamo
ok perfetto c'è ragazzi dovremmo essere
la porta era el poemi questo c'era
scritto prima si c'era scritto 1500
matera 1599 ok no bastardo ha sbagliato
niente sbaglio cosmico siamo fin tutta
la vita ragazzo è ok perché fai così
devo entrare qui dentro ma non mi piace
entra giusto posto perché prima c'era
qualcuno dio mio che cosa brutta perché
non vedo nulla ragazze poi pre up
perfetto posso segnare gli oggetti come
si fa segnare gli oggetti metterlo tipo
come faccio a rassegna perfetto dalla
iii il coltello lo mettiamo su uno
perfetto lo facciamo così 3 ok ragazzi
siamo così posso fare lo switch più
veloce che ci siamo ragazzi e non mi
piace il suo posto non mi piace ma
andiamo avanti lo stesso perché sala
gando cosa succede avanti o sinistra
laica ditemelo
andiamo a sinistra va bene no veramente
avanti aperto
raga
andiamo a sinistra non mi piace andare
avanti è chiusa porca [ __ ] che cazzo
invece qualcuno lì io vado di qua vado
di comodo di qua non posso andare di qua
stronzo
se provi a saltarmi addosso tutti salto
addosso anche ok è chiuso ha chiuso apri
bastardo apre ma non pensavo la festa
davvero ora è ok che è successo arrivato
un messaggio tim ti segnaliamo che c'è
un'offerta guarda a destra
la gaia lì dentro non c entra perché
devo entrare schiera che devo entrare
qui dentro perché va bene lo stesso da
chi è chiamato a chi è che ha il mio
numero
maledizione la luce che non vedo niente
cos'è questo cos'è sta roba una
registrazione e guarda a destra è il
messaggio c'è ancora guarda devo
guardare sempre a destra praticamente no
cos'è che sta dicendo lì sopra è
prevista il mouse 2 per fare un attacco
corpo a corpo con la tua arma che non so
cosa è successo cosa che cosa sta
succedendo ragazzo cos'è cos'è sono mani
a una porta non si capiva o cazzo cazzo
c'è del sangue sul terreno
raga dietro dietro è si è chiusa come
cazzo fatto arrivare fino qui non lo so
c'è il martello c'è il marte grazie a
dio il martello di thor e aprono lo
prego non ha preso io e martello non ho
preso io il mart è frutto stronzo che tp
accade a calci in faccia
beh ballo addio
[Musica]
corrente di tutto strappa sardo ti
prendo a pugni ti prende ma porca
[ __ ] maga il coltello il coltello
kazaka brutto stronzo stanca si è visto
sto bene ho vinto chi era quello a lo so
devo chiamare la polizia mi prendi per
il culo che sei a narnia provocazione
chiami la polizia non ci sarà neanche
campo mamma va sicché genio non lo so
veramente non l'avevano anche previsto
cioè proprio che sorpresa non c'è campo
tra l'altro dov'è andato a finire il
corpo mia mi ha tolto metà vita cazzo
vabbè c'era gae inquietantissimo store
cos'è una siringa e un drogato anche qui
non va bene anche in grecia le siringhe
perché devono esserci trovati sti giochi
e vabbè andiamo di sotto la parte da un
dato di sotto per vedere qui sotto per
chiede perché vi consiglia questi giochi
oddio
e brutto bastardo tutto strano ma non mi
era stato mai fuori ma perché migliore
beccare ok marzo la draga che brutto ma
vera chiedevo devo andare avanti storico
addio cosa vi ha o no ma cosa c'è il
collo storto e ora fatemi entrare qui
fatevi 3 qui avvio il frutto stronzo
mori muori bastardo crepa crepa crepa
muori a iosa mi sta uccidendo ok ce l'ho
fatta ma posso prenderlo il martello
tipo no non posso prendere ma allora
cosa ci faccio qui
raga aiuto non è che ce n'è ancora uno
basta c'è una scala perfetta così sono
arrivato non c'è una scala proprio che
perfetto ragazze non mi piace voglio sai
come si salva in sto gioco forse il
registratore forse posso registra
perfetto quasi salva ok salva sullo slot
1 al vero non si utilizziamo tutto
daccapo revi due volte da sé direzionali
per schivare in una specifica direzione
a figo oddio cos'è bastardo no no aiuta
addio visto però visto bastardi no mi ha
stuprato dio mio santo ragazzi io la
voglio chiudere qui per questo episodio
mi sei piaciuto correre solito lasciato
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione 6 ma siete accorsi
iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo in un
prossimo vitobello ragazzi